jake always knows that how uh my
questions will determine how much i
enjoyed a movie very true right he we've
he's informed me about this um you do
not have to worry this is a [ __ ] good
movie okay sorry for my cursing i
apologize no that's actually another
telltale sign yeah i mean this is good
cursing by you is actually an
affirmative so see what i mean listen i
got tons of questions and they're all
over the place so let's get started for
all three of you if someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
a movie called
all day in the night
because that's the closest
that i to me that i've ever seen myself
on
on film and i'm only in it for you know
i've maybe have three or four scenes in
it but i think it's kind of nice i play
a lot of characters but that's probably
the closest that i've seen my cell phone
feel closest to me that i've seen myself
um i would say
[Music]
i care a lot i really like i care a lot
and i think it's
the first movie that i was given the
opportunity to play more of a grounded
realistic character and not sort of
think that baby driver opened the door
for me and sort of
characters that were big and very um
yeah character pieces and this is more
of a grounded performance and it's a bit
of a love story so
it feels more of in the line that i like
to do the things that i like to do
bubble boy yes 100 absolutely i think
yes it's a good introduction i i would
agree i agree it was my introduction
it's mine too was it yeah yeah oh boy
there we go
they still wanted to work with me so
here we are
no i i mean i uh yeah there you go uh
for all three of you what is the most
you've actually prepared for any role
that you've done
preparation is so different from job to
job sometimes it's physical sometimes
there's so much effort going into like a
physical
like changing my body physically
other times it's been the effort that it
takes to learn
a new language
uh to be able to speak a new language it
really all depends yeah
you want an answer i mean i would like
one but you have to get one yeah i think
i think that's what my answer is gonna
be
yeah i agree i think that um
i prepared a lot for baby driver because
i was really nervous and funny enough
he's talking about language and it was a
language that i felt very um
stressed over because obviously english
is my second language and it was my
first movie ever in a different language
so and i was really nervous and i i was
stepping into a set with
really incredible actors and i really
wanted to be up to
the level they were so i really really
really really overly prepared like even
for my audition so hard i can't even
imagine doing a
film in another language it's hard i
mean this was really hard to i would say
this for the language because it's all
the medical jargon and it has to seem
completely seamless so
obviously
that became really challenging when we
were in a writing ambulance 100 miles
per hour you're so stressed over it that
you can't even think about language
truly
well i have two answers to that i would
say the longest liter quite literally
was
maybe when i was preparing and trying to
learn how to box for southpaw
but then the the the more philosophical
answer to that
which uh i know you'll be interested in
steve is
i think you're always preparing for the
next role and every single one is about
preparation into the next you know you
carry with you all the stuff that you
have in your life and you bring it into
the work that you do and you learn and
you evolve and each each thing you drag
all the other stuff with you
uh for all again for all three of you uh
what is the hardest take you have ever
done in any of your movies the one that
like either for camera reasons or
performance or a mixture of camera and
performance is there one that you will
always remember is like oh my god that
was
another level
well i can give you i can give you uh
the literal answer which is probably has
something to do with uh with uh aquaman
and uh it's it's the first aquaman and
i'm i'm shooting in this tank
that sort of uh this it submerges and so
we have to beat the
i have to
to
finish the moment with my dad and then
get to the other side of the tank before
i'm completely submerged so by the time
i'm i'm
i'm i'm at the end of the take it's like
the water is
you know this is like up to my mouth
and that's a that that was a
technically you know
difficult to execute
um but i think we're always in the
middle of the most difficult takes
in our lives you know you're always
preparing for the next take uh because
life will throw
objectives at you and you have to be
ready to uh
you know to take them on yeah
i think for me uh acting was
it was a very hard scene that i had to
shoot i don't want to spoil it and i
care a lot something happens to her and
i have to really cry and it's a very
emotional scene
and it really opened like a can of worms
for me so it was really really hard to
disconnect from the scene afterwards
um and then physically
i would say funny enough it's underwater
too i did this movie where i had a by
when i started the film i had an
accident i broke my collarbone and three
ribs so at the time that we were ending
the movie i had to do this stunt
underwater in a tank and i was doing jiu
jitsu underwater completely waiting
it was on my third month i had recovered
so we left it till the last day of
shooting but i really wanted to do it i
really pushed my team because they
wanted to do it with someone else and it
was it was very challenging physically
and it was scary but i felt very
satisfied when i saw the final
cut yeah it was worth it
nothing really
nothing it's hard for jake truly not
really uh uh i mean look it's it's
acting so
i don't know if you can call that hard
but i
um i do remember like one scene in this
movie stronger that i did that was
not just not not because it was um
difficult for me but difficult to think
about
someone having gone through that for
real
i think that's that's sometimes like
being in that space is like
uh and then trying to do that service is
is is this the strange thing in in
acting and performance because you're
pretending right and so but getting into
that space trying to understand what was
real something that actually happened
it's
that's hard
you